اعتدنا في صباح العربيه على اختيار شخصيه
الاسبوع كل يوم خميس الشخصيه التي
اخترناها اليوم شخصيه معنويه اخترناها
بالتزامن مع العقاد اكبر لقاء لاصحاب
النفوس في العالم بين ثلوج قريه دافوس
السويسريه شخصيتنا لليوم هي رجل دافوس رجل
دافوس عباره ابتكرها عالم السياسه السمو
الهندي مع بدايه الالفيه الحاليه وتحديدا
عام 2004 نتذكر ان الكاتب نفسه هو من
اخترع مصطلح صدام الحضارات رجل دافوس هو
دلاله واضحه على الشخص الغني وينتمي الى
نخبه من صناع القرار حيث الولاء للعولمه
والمصلحه الاقتصاديه المحركه لكل محوله
يبدو رجل دافوس بالنسبه
الارقام ونسب انه امكانياته لكن حتى رجل
دافوس يتغير ويبدو ان العالم يتوجه اكثر
الى سيده ذا فويس تعني
اكثر التنميه وبالبيئه وبشئون مستقبل
الانسان الفت هذا العام انه مع حضور اكثر
من 3000 متعو الى ان المؤتمر يشهد غياب
احد اكبر من يمكن ان يلقب برجل دافوس في
السنوات الاخيره لملياردير الين ماسك الذي
قال انه يقاطع المنتدى بين مقال المنتزه
ان ماسك لم تتم دعوته اصلا
[موسيقى]
وائل وائل
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]